için Eyvah suyu doğruyor 2012 yılı olan
veyahut yönetime mail açıklama yapıyor
Mayıs ama hayır yavrunun yeni siyosu
olacak yahu son 5 yılda 7'si
yerleştirmiş Manisa Hayır daha 37
yaşında da iki teknoloji ve Ekibi
arasında önemli bir geçiş ve basına
kamuoyuna Bu haliyle yansıyacağı yani
Fortune 500 şirketleri arasındaki en
genç kadın seviyorsun 37 yaşında siyah
olacağını herkesin konuşacağız alırken
eş zamanlı olarak başka bir haber
düşüyor Medya
o dönemde ve Ona rağmen ya ona teklif
yapıyor ve aradaki dönemi kapatıp
kendisi Yahu daki İlk birkaç ayında
geçirdikten sonra hayır doğum yapıyor
oğlum şu anda 7 yaşında arada üstüne
geçiyor ve bihaber daha düşüyor Medya
Manisa Hayır gene hamile bu sefer ikiz
gene yer yerinden oynuyor sermaye
piyasaları Yav gibi bir şirketin
seviyorsun hamile olmasının şirket
performansını nasıl etkileyeceği
tartışmaya başlıyor böyle bir şeyin
olamayacağı ve şirketin Bunlar olumsuz
etkileneceği haberleri bir şekilde
yayılıyor ama daha ilginç bir tartışma
var ki Bir taraftan da hepiniz kanat
yine doğumdan birkaç hafta sonra geri
döneceğini açıklayan Manisa ayrı neden
çocuklarıyla daha fazla git
bu değiştirmeye başlıyor Yani kimseye
yaranamıyorsun Hayır Eyvah syo doğuruyor
diye feryat ediyor Bütün dünya Halbuki
kadınların iş hayatında elde ettiği
entellektüel takvimin Has çalışmayan
annelere göre çocukların zihinsel
gelişiminin daha hızlı olduğunu
gösteriyor yapılan akademik araştırmalar
Ama buna rağmen eleştiriyorum böyle bir
noktaya geliyor ki konuya Keşke bu işe
kalkışmadan önce bize Danış saydınız
diyor toplum eyvah ses yok doğruyu Eyvah
suyu doğru cümlesine Eminim çok az
duyduğunuz Ben de çok az uyumuştum Oğlum
bu iş ayı duyduktan sonra Acaba dedim
Amerika'daki siyahların çocukları
olmamış mı onlarca
bu binlerce kez seviyorlar çocuk sahibi
olmuşlar ama basiyor baba olduğunda hiç
kimse görmemiş suyu anne olduğunda Eyvah
siyo doğuruyor Ne yapacağız şimdi ve bu
O noktaya kadar gelmişken Amerika'daki
Sermaye Piyasası regülatör isek Yahu ve
Manisa Mahiri uzak altına alan bir
araştırma başlatıyor Acaba küçük
yatırımcıların ise performansından
dolayı zarar görmesi söz konusu olur
musun hamile olmasın Eyvah şey yok
doğruyu o kadar az duyuyoruz gibi
cümleyi Amerikalılar enteresan
araştırmalar yapıyorlar Amerika'daki
Cami simli videoların sayısı kadınlarda
fazla iktidardaki cumhuriyetçi Parti
dc-10 isimli senatörlerin sayısı kadın
çok fazla istek araştırma seven bir
toplum değiliz ama biz de yapsak bu
ratway Mehmet Emin'in kadınlardan daha
fazla iş hayatında da sayılar arasında
da alimento da ya da yerel yönetimler di
Eyvah siyah doğuruyor Ben stratejik
yönetici atamaları ile uğraşıyorum
farklı sektörlerde değişik
organizasyonlar beni davet ediyorlar ve
kurumlarındaki TP boşluklarında veya
değişikliğinde benim hizmetlerinden
danışmanlarından yararlanıyorlar bundan
Birkaç yıl önce dünyanın başka bir
ucunda bir iş toplantısını tamamlayıp
otel odasına çıktım ve günün son gelen
mesajları cevaplamaya çalışırken telefon
çal telefondaki isim son dönemde uzun
bir şekilde üzerinde çaba harcadım
Türkiye'nin en büyük gruplarından
sağ üst düzey bir yönetici rolü ile
ilgili olarak bütün süreçleri
tamamlanmış mülakatlardan geçmiş
değerlendirmeleri yapmış ve o gün Birkaç
saat önce imza atmaya o şirkete gitmesi
gereken bir kadın yöneticiydi işte
görünce ya teşekkür etme yarıyor diye
düşündüm ya da beyin hep kötüye
çalışıyor ya Eyvah şey oluyor Telefonu
açtım kadın yönetici Birkaç saat önce
başına gelenleri anlattı imza atmak
üzere ilgili şirketin insan kaynakları
yöneticisi oranı randevusuna giderken
Hatta merkez ofisi birkaç metre kala
Telefonu çalıyor telefonda biraz sonra
görüşmesi gereken insan kaynakları
yöneticisi insan kaynakları yöneticisi
diyor ki biz çok heyecanlıyız sizinle
çok iyi şeyler yapar
çok seviyoruz videomuz aynı görüşte İyi
ki bu işleri kuracağız Çok teşekkürler
Yalnız bir küçük konu var En son
suyumuza yaptığımız görüşmede şeker
olduğunuzdan ve yakın zamanda evlenmeyi
bile anladığınızdan bahsetmişsiniz Evet
diyordun küçük bir ricası var Önümüzdeki
iki yıl abraka Ahmet ama sizi olan
güvenimiz o kadar tam ki unu sözlü
olarak söylemeniz yeterli yani Kontrol
falan yazmayalım sonra düşündüm Keşke
hastalar the bayağı bir olay olurdu
Burada yönetici ad2 Murat Bey kusura
bakmayın samimiyet sınırları içinde
konuşuyoruz ama ben bekarım eşi açık
arkadaşım da yok Peki evlensem de hem
ne yapmak gibi planında Yok güzel ama
ben Bu şirketle çalışmak istemiyorum
bütün Tadım arzun isteğin kaçtın
hayırlıdır geri döndü çok önemli değil
ama parantez içinde söylüyorum o kadın
hala bekar mutlu mesut o şirkette
çalışıyor çocuğum Peki onun Hayır dediği
rol boş kaldı mı ayrı hoş kalmadı Ve
eminim başka bir pavitte ona birisi oldu
işte Aslı okul kutlar ne kadar çok boş
kalırsa iki sene doğum yapmayın deme
cüretini gösteren seviyorlar gerçeklerle
yüzleşmeye başlayacak O bilinçsiz
önyargıların ne anlama geldiğini bir
şekilde anlamaya başlayacaklar bu olay
başıma geldiğinde bir gazetede diyordum
bu isimlere yuvalara vesaire bahsetmeden
kısaca hikaye yazdım birçok geri dönüş
oldu benzer konularda kadınlar başına
gelenleri anlattılar enteresan larından
bir tanesi Yeni doğum yapmış bir şey ve
işe geri dönmüştük kadın yönetici
yöneticisinden kendi patrondan çok
önemli bir proje almış çok mutlu mesut
kolları sıvayıp işe başlamış İlk
görüşmede patronun çağırmış demiş ki
önümüzdeki hafta İstanbul dışında şurada
kalmam gerekecek Çünkü o proje için Uşak
demiş ki çok isterim ama biliyorsunuz
ben süt veriyorum her gün belirli
saatlerde Tamam önemli değil hafta
sorabilirsiniz
Sen hiç hafta sonra bir sütü kendi öyle
yazıyor herhalde
bu Eyvah doğruyu bilinçsiz on yargılar
12 milyonluk insanlık tarihinde en az
gelişen organ hangisi biliyor musunuz
genelde yüzleri gördüğümde atıştırmalar
görüyorum ama sandığınız organ değil
değil En az gelişen organ beyin 2 milyon
önceki beyinle şu andaki benim
fizyolojik yapısı ve çalışması arasında
çok az farklılıklar veriyoruz var ve biz
bu beyine bütün önemli kararlarımızı
belediye ediyoruz ve o bilinçsiz
önyargılarla zaman zaman düşünmeden
kararlar vermesini bekliyoruz ben çoğu
zaman verdiği kararları bu envanterdeki
ön yargılarıyla ya da iyileştirdiği bir
takım bilgiler ya da ona söylenenlerle
yapmaya çalışıyor ama biz gene de beyine
hiç düşünmeden o kararları verme
yetisini derece ediyoruz ve o beyin
bedava
bu adam gelen bir takım söylemlerle
kadından olmaz diyor kadından iş insanı
olmaz diyor kadından yönetim kurulu
üyesi olmaz diyor kadında sanatçı olmaz
diyor ardından sporcu olmaz kadınar
taşıyamaz dün akşam çıkamaz Bunların
hepsi de ne hale geliyor Ha bir de 0-6
yaş dönemi var 0-6 yaş döneminde beynin
gelişimine önemli katkı tamamlanıyor
Yani evde annenin babanın anneye hitabı
ilişkileri iletişimlerini evde okunan
okunmayan gazeteler kitaplar hele şu
anda gele vizyonlarda diziler filmler
reklamlar Bunların hepsi o06 yaşta beyni
sünger gibi işleniyor ve şimdi biz Ondan
sonraki 60-70 yıl da bütün bu ön
yargıları işlemleri ve değiştirmeye
çalışıyoruz bunları değiştirmeye
Ya aslında Bunlar benim önyargıları
bildiklerim tecrübelerini demiyoruz çoğu
zaman karşı taraftaki işaret ediyoruz
bir araştırma şirketi Türkiye'de
yapılmış ve Araştırma Bence araştırmanın
başlığı yanlış Ama gene de enteresan
sonuçları var araştırmanın başlığı bu
erkeklerin sevmekten en az hoşlandıkları
ev işte yapmaktan hoşlandıkları iştir
sanki hoşlandıkları kısım varmış gibi
ama yapmaktan en az hoşlandıkları işte
vaktimi sinirle yoksa sizlere soracaktım
ama ilk üçü söylüyorum cam silme Erdal
atmak balkon yıkayıp 3. özelliğini
biliyor musunuz dışarıdan gözükenler
Aman dışarıdakiler görmesin beni
Türkiye'de kararlarımız adresi Raider
çok basit polise konuşmayacağız dedik
ama çok tehlikeli bir örgüt var ve bütün
bize olan nüfusuyla yaralarımız
veriyoruz Elalem örgütü Elalem örgütü ne
der diye hayatımızı yönlendiriyoruz ve
Elalem o erkeği evde asarken bal koyup
erken yiyecekleri nedeniyle hayatımızı
bir şekilde yönlendiriyoruz meselenin
aslına 3 boyutu var ben dışarıda
çeşitlilik bu salondaki gibi renkli
enerjisi Yüksel farklı ara Farklı
geçmişlerden gelen kadın erkek yaş
çeşitli bir grubu bir odaya
topluyorsunuz Biz bunu da ayrılmış
durumda değil sadece Türkiye'de değil
dünyada verilmiştir aslında Çok da zor
değil kapıda durup disiplinli bir
şekilde kafaları sayıyı olsanız vermek
kolay daha sonra bu topladığınız
kalabalığı bu renkli kalabalığı enerjisi
yüksek kalabalığı
bu müzikle aynı melodiyle ayağa kaldırıp
bahsettiren biliyor musunuz İşte o
kapsayıcılık o daha da sor daha oraya
gelemedim ama bizim hala mücadele
ettiğimiz Bütün bunların müsebbibi olan
kısım bilinçsiz o yargılar bu dünyada
filarmoni orkestraları ve 70'li yılların
sonuna kadar tamamı erkeklerden oluşan
rüzgarlarda oluşturmuş kadınlar jürinin
değerlendirmeleri Geçemem işler ne kadar
İnşallah varsa çalsınlar şimdi kabul
etmemiş kadınların müzisyen
alabileceğimiz 80'li yılların başında
Boston planı de bir sürü arkadaşım demiş
ki ya her şeyi denedik bir şey daha
deneyelim şu sahnenin önüne bir perde
çekelim arkada kimin müzik yaptığı
anlaşılmaz bir gecede 150/60 kadın bir
şeylerin seçim orada değil Çünkü kadın
erkek olduğuna bakarak değil çıkmaya
bakarak karar vermeye başlamış ve
oturuyor baktığın
ve o kaliteli müzikle o armonide içeriye
almış Daha sonra dünyanın Başka bir
yerinde başka bir sivri akıllı çıkmış
demiş ki kulesinin arkasından kadınlar
perdenin arkasına gelirken yüksek
topuklu ayakkabıları çıkarsınlar topuk
sesini duyunca jüri anlıyor kadın
olduğunu çarpılıyor Yani bilinçsiz on
yargılar başka bir sanat dalında da
Charlotte bronte Jane yazarı Bir Erkek
ismiyle ancak Çayeli basacak bir bulmuş
kardeşleri de aynı şekilde üç kızkardeş
üçüde yazar üçü de erkek isimleri de
basmışlar eserlerin küçük kadınların
Gözlerim elimiz a6p Evet gizemli akut
1900 1860'lı yıllarda 50 romanları
yazarken Ey bernardin diyeyim
bu çünkü başka türlü 100 lira bulamamış
zaten imkanı Mary pope Zin yazarı aynı
şekilde ceal çağırmış bir kadın hepsi
kadın hepsi ya 100 lira gitmişler ve
yayıncılar demiş ki kadından yazar olmaz
okumaz kimse almaz mı bizim bu ismi
değiştirmemiz lazım Ha diyebilirsiniz ki
yüzyıllar geçti 90'lı yılların en büyük
nedenlerinden bir tanesi Harry Harry
Potter Harry Potter'ın yazarı ceker
rolling gerçek ismi o Tuana katli
rolling ama Yayınları gittiğinde gençler
demişler ki Süper Roman ama erkek
çocuklar kadını yazdığı okumaz
birleştirme şimdi bütün bu
konuştuklarımızın arkasında toplumsal
cinsiyet eşitliği var Biz toplumsal
cinsiyet eşitliğinde eşit fırsatlara
eşit imkanları erkeklerin Sahip
olduklarına kadınların da sahip olmasını
savunuyoruz ama bunu yapabilmenin yolu
Nevin bahse
bu gibi çeşitliliğini sağlamaya uğraşmak
kafa saymaktan değil demin konuştuğumuz
bilinçsiz on yargıları değişmekten
değiştirmekten geçiyor ve bilinçsiz
önyargıları değiştirme mücadelesine
başlarken de başlangıç noktası Bu
erkekler bu konu bir kadın meselesi
değil bu konu bir erkek misiniz Biz
kadına şiddeti değil erkek şiddetini
konuşmamız lazım kadın cinayetleri değil
erkeklerin işlediği cinayetleri en
sevdiklerine annelerine eşlerine
sevgililerine ablalarına Kardeşlerine ve
hatta kızlarına yönelik işlenen
cinayetleri ve uyguladıkları şiddet işte
buradan yola çıkarak da 40 tane erkek
geçen sene yanındayız diye bir dernek
kurduk amacımız erkek diline ve erkek
zihniyetine erkeklerin Akif oldukları
stadyumda kafede berber dükkanında
kışlada Hatta camilerde değiştirecek
aksiyonla
Bu etkinlikte yapabilmek ve bunun
mücadelesi için bu mücadele ancak
erkeklerdeki bu zihinsel farkı
değişiklik yaratır Sak toplumsal
cinsiyet eşitliği bir anlamda bir adım
daha ileriye gidebilir inancındayız Ben
sizi Yollarında olmasını istiyorum ben
kadınların erkeklerin sahip olduğu hak
ve fırsatları ulaşmasını istiyorum ben
kadınların o hak ve fırsatlara sahip
olmasını istiyor Birleşmiş Milletler'in
eşitlik elçisi ve iyi porchy
etkinliğinde sözcüsü Emma iki tane çok
basit soruyu soruyor bir tanesi He şimdi
değilse ne zaman bir tanesi de her sabah
ben kalktığımda kendime sorduğum sorunun
bende sevdim ben değilsem
O biraz önce av Serter dedi ya dünyayı
değiştirelim diye ve Sahip olduğunuz o
zaman siz de aynı soruyu sorun bende
insan Kim değiştirecek Dünyası alacaktık